[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
buscando alejarse de las polémicas
políticas migratorias del anterior
gobierno republicano en eeuu el gobierno
de joe biden instruyó a sus agentes
migratorios para evitar separar a padres
o tutores de sus hijos o familiares una
vía que comenzará a hacerse efectiva de
inmediato en la anterior administración
entre 2017 y 2018 más de 5000 menores
fueron alejados de sus seres queridos
ahora la política migratoria pretende
ser más justa ordenada y humana
caída la noche en yuma este grupo de
personas logró cruzar la frontera
salieron de cuba perú venezuela y
colombia y llegaron a eeuu después de
varias semanas
ya estoy dentro de la frontera yo soy
americano
mejores
ya
un beso grande dice lo mismo
queda todavía la historia es similar en
todos los casos buscan oportunidades
trabajo y un futuro mejor pedidos que
parecen lejanos en sus países tuve un
sueño deseado de mucho tiempo
a leer
a rehacer una nueva vida cosas mejores
para poder ayudar a la familia
primero por mejoras económicas ya no se
puede vivir en otro momento la situación
es difícil
y para que decirle los apagones no hay
luz eléctrica no hay petróleo no hay
gasolina la situación se torna difícil
en cuba agentes de la patrulla
fronteriza los reciben y procesan y
ahora tomarán medidas adicionales para
no separar de manera forzada a padres y
documentos de sus hijos o para alejar a
tutores de sus familiares o encargados
me arrepentí en muchos momentos voy a
arrepentir pero
yo estoy aquí sports por mis hermanos y
por mi familia
hay que hacer un sacrificio por la
familia los oficiales del servicio de
control de inmigración y aduanas tendrán
ahora que indagar y registrar la
relación de los migrantes y los menores
con los que cruzan la frontera para
evitar a repetir las polémicas
separaciones familiares reportadas en el
pasado la niña esa fue mi preocupación
siempre la barrida
que no fuera pasarle nada
y que todos salieron en mi deseo
principalmente primero que todo
que le voy a dar la dicha de nacer es
una tierra de libertad
que en cuba murió a porcel no lo iba a
poder tener el mal dicho
y
qué va a pasar en el país de la granda
oportunidad la nueva directiva también
permite que los padres o tutores
deportados previamente regresen a eeuu
de forma temporal para las audiencias de
custodia de sus hijos
pero el camino hasta la frontera sur de
eeuu es peligroso y nada garantiza
llegar a puerto las rutas son múltiples
y así mismo los riesgos la muerte de 53
migrantes por deshidratación y
hacinamiento que viajaban en un camión
en texas enluta sus familias 10 de
quienes fallecieron eran adolescentes
algunos menores migrantes que viajaban
solos desde centroamérica sus cuerpos
comenzaron a retornar a sus países de
origen el informes de laurel a
familiares y amigos dijeron adiós por
última vez a pasqual melvin guau sexy
para que el adolescente indígena de tres
años es el primer repatriado de los 21
guatemaltecos de la tragedia de texas en
eeuu el 27 de junio un empleado
municipal de san antonio encontró a 67
personas asignadas en un camión
sobrecalentado 48 de ellas que ya habían
fallecido por asfixia y me llamara como
a las cinco y media de la tarde
un compañero llegó a tu hijo no
y no es por su estado de verdad
la noticia que pasó una tragedia quien
sana y investiga me dijo y yo en ese
momento empecé a investigar
investigar que intenta llamar su celular
que ya no contesta en minutos también
un cabal que a iván en el trailer desde
entonces las autoridades tratan de
identificar a cada una de las víctimas
para entregarlas a sus familias los
cuerpos de 25 de los 26 migrantes
mexicanos fallecidos ya llegaron a su
país dentro de los que están los de
estos tres primos de la localidad de san
marcos a tex y lapan buscaban emigrar a
eeuu para encontrar un trabajo mejor
remunerado si el trabajo del mexicano es
tan preciado en los eeuu no es válido
hacerlo de manera ilegal no es válido
que ellos caminen para la derecha y la
autoridad golpe para la izquierda según
la organización internacional para las
migraciones desde 2014 unos seis mil 430
migrantes han muerto desaparecido en su
camino en busca del llamado sueño
americano
y los peligros del recorrido no son
menores pese a las medidas del gobierno
de eeuu que garantizan la no separación
de familias hambre robos abusos de todo
tipo e incluso la muerte son algunos de
los riesgos además llegar hasta la
frontera no significa lograr el ingreso
y el dato de migración de la semana
1400 10 cubanos fueron devueltos a su
país durante este 2022 desde mexico se
trata de emigrantes que transitaban el
territorio rumbo a eeuu según la oficina
de aduanas y protección fronteriza en
los primeros 8 meses del actual año
fiscal llegaron más de 140 mil cubanos
vía terrestre a las fronteras
estadounidenses
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]